for some life simple so what's your deal
man what do you do I'm a comedian
ah you hate to hear that for David
nothing's easy it's like if I was 5%
funnier I'd be a millionaire and if I
was 30% less funny I'd be a
multimillionaire
but when times are hard the laughs are
harder we're here protesting the lack of
diversity on campus there's too many
white males like you how you make me
look like Nat King Cole you gotta pay
your taxes everybody take 40 what
happened was I went into a coma in my 20
well you must have been in a dark place
I was a theatre see what's got everyone
talking ah you are you
kidding me man nobody wants to you
oh this is a library
starring David Angelo's he did John
Mulaney this isn't exactly the
networking opportunity I thought it
would be and introducing Andrew mic on
so if fun is your thing the late-night
parties allowed music the wild sex I
mean those are things I report to the
cops all the time come along for the
ride
tune in October 3rd well let me see if I
can clear my schedule and will promise I
tell you nothing nothing's easy